I have started using infrared sauna my whole life. I've been terrible sweater.
So I think what you mean you don't sweat well. Most people I would say that they're a terrible
sweater in this world, sweat horribly or terrible sweater could be used this time of year
in a ugly Christmas sweater contest. But I know what you mean you don't sweat a lot. I can sit in
the sauna for 20 minutes and 140, 145 and barely sweat. If I walk on a treadmill for 30 minutes
before getting to the sauna, then I do sweat better. Do you have any recommendation encouragement
for my body to sweat? Yeah, that is hard. Some people have told me in the past that they just
do not sweat. They've never sweat. They don't sweat but they're outside. Those are all bad signs.
You need to get your body sweating. So if you find that walking on a treadmill for 30 minutes
and then doing the sauna, I have had people say they don't sweat, they've gotten the sauna,
they don't sweat and the more that they do the sauna, more frequently, they do the sauna, the more
they sweat. So that you might find that to be true too. So I don't know if you just got the
sauna just recently. If that's true, you may find that the more you are doing the soda, the more
you are sweating, make sure you're fully hydrated too. So some people don't sweat because they just
don't drink water. Their body is just holding fluid. So make sure your decent hydration